[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEPHANIE WONG: Container
Threat Detection, KTD,
is a built-in service in
Security Command Center
Premium.
It can detect the most common
container runtime attacks
and provide alerts in
Security Command Center,
and optionally in Cloud Logging.
Container Threat
Detection includes
multiple detection capabilities,
an analysis tool, and an API.
To enable Container
Threat Detection,
first make sure you have
Security Command Center
admin and Security
Center sources
admin IAM rules, along with
the SCC Premium subscription.
On the SCC homepage,
go to the Sources page.
If you're a premium Security
Command Center subscriber,
you can click the toggle next
to Container Threat Detection
to enable it.
In your Cloud SCC
dashboard, you will
find the Container
Threat Detection
card listing current findings.
In our environment,
there is one finding.
Some examples of the types of
findings that KTD can surface
include added binary executions.
This finding triggers
when a binary
that was not part of the
original container image
was executed.
If an added binary is
executed, it's a possible sign
that an attacker has
control of the workload,
and they are executing
unwanted software
such as malware or
cryptocurrency mining software.
Added binary loaded.
This finding triggers
when a library
that was not part of the
original container image
was loaded.
If an added library is
loaded, it's a possible sign
that an attacker has
control of the workload,
and they are executing
arbitrary code.
Reverse shell.
This finding triggers
when a process
started with stream redirection
to a remote-connected socket.
An attacker can
use reverse shell
to communicate
from a compromised
workload to an
attacker-controlled machine.
With this capability,
the attacker
can control the workload to
perform malicious actions,
for example as part of a botnet.
You can learn more about these
detections in the documentation
link below.
When Container Threat
Detection generates findings,
you can view them in
Security Command Center,
or in Cloud Logging, if you
have configured Security Command
Centers Syncs to write to
Google Cloud's Operation Suite.
To produce sample
findings for us to act on,
we've set up a cluster on
Kubernetes Engine in a project
within our organization.
Using Cloud Shell, you can
trigger an added binary
executed finding by dropping
a binary in our container
and executing it.
Once we access the
Cluster Control Plane,
we can deploy the latest
Ubuntu 18.04 image,
copy /bin/ls to another
location, and then execute it.
You can trigger a
reverse shell finding,
by deploying the latest
Ubuntu 18.04 image
and copying in a
library that was not
part of the original
container image.
This example deploys the latest
Ubuntu 18.04 image, copies
the library, libcso6,
to another location,
and then loads it using ld.
You can also trigger a
reverse shell finding
by starting a binary with
standard input redirection
to a TCP-connected socket.
This example starts /bin/echo
with redirection to the Google
public DNS 8.8.8.8
on the DNS port.
You can find these
commands in the link below.
To view findings, navigate
to the Threats Dashboard
in Security Command Center.
Our findings are listed
as critical threats.
Drilling in, you can
find detailed information
on the Source Properties tab
about the source container,
including environment
variables, process arguments,
and Kubernetes labels.
You can share this finding
with your team and remediate
by heading to the source.
Congratulations.
You've just completed setting
up Container Threat Detection.
You can now detect
and be alerted
to the most common
container runtime attacks
from the Google Cloud console
or Cloud Audit Logging.
[MUSIC PLAYING]